in bedrooms across the globe
virtual money is being spent on in-game
extras
the latest must-have additions to stay
bang up to date on games like fortnite
but that virtual currency comes with a
real-life price tag and it's how players
buy that digital dosh
that's the issue game developers have to
use
apple's app store to sell anything to
iphone and ipad users
all at a cost and now fortnite's
developers epic
have had enough to lose epic is a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
have enormously deep pockets and so what
we're looking at here
where in the past we've had david
vigolia cases this is
goliath they have the pockets to take
apple on
and try to convince the courts that
apple have an unfair advantage that they
have a monopoly
over the apps you're able to put on an
iphone fortnite itself is free
but players can buy v-bucks on the app
store for add-ons like outfits and
weapons
apple then takes a 30 cut of the money
paid for the virtual currency
it's good business in the last three
years apple has made 260 million pounds
from fortnite sales alone the problem
came when epic decided to allow fortnite
users to buy v-bucks direct
and at a discount apple retaliated by
removing the game from the app store
the developer's response was a revamp of
the famous 1984 apple ad
pitching chief executive tim cook as the
baddie
but apple says its terms of service are
clear in return providing safety and
security for customers
although the company's not taking any
chances bringing out the big guns
we continue to be committed to making an
impact in people's lives
tim cook seen here at a recent product
launch is among the executives expected
to testify during the trial
app store is the crown jewel of apple
and this is something they're not taken
lightly and apple has really come back
aggressively on this
fortnite isn't the first to take on
apple but with the current court case
so much is at stake success for
fortnight's makers would be an
epic victory not just for them but all
app developers
and a slippery slope for apple's
stronghold on the market
emma birchley sky news